hello and welcome to this small but
interesting video yeah i'm going to
upload this video because i want to
point you to something interesting and
interesting new chat site and one
reasons why I am the way on that side is
because they I'm on it yeah I'm on it
with an interview this is an interview
side podcast site where chess players
chess personality somehow our interview
denim very much honored to be a 6 mm
sodium it's a perpetual chest podcast
hosted by Ben Johnson bears a really
good player and his own concern where's
it's about I think here on a boundary of
something about then he acted here is
now it's a good master level player and
he's doing interviews with them yeah
it's jeff persons yeah we've got them
you know i think so OH him yeah we have
I'm the latest turn a latest episode
from from last week and we've got the
Grandmaster Sam Williams on down costs
jackboots key now if I keep server
condom women on champion of them of the
of the u.s. Grand Master yang Gustafson
and Greg shoddy so Elliot we've got zero
into an episode yeah so this good stuff
is really fun to listen to those
interviews and yankin yeah listen to to
my interview that was done last week but
the other ones also of course very much
interesting so when you point out point
this out to you and it deserves a couple
of days it's really a good good site and
promising site to visit yeah thanks for
watching go check it out bye bye